Hello, I'm Timothy
Jordan, and this
is your update about all
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
I have just a few
updates to share,
so let's see how fast I
can get you back to work.
Speaking of fast,
Android Studio 2.0
is the fastest way to build
high-quality performant
apps for the Android
platform, including
phones and tablets, Android
Auto, Android Wear, and Android
TV.
If you are developing
for Android,
you should be using
Android Studio 2.0.
Check out the blog post for
the latest features and a link
to the latest stable release.
In this week's Android
Developer story,
WeVideo explains how relaunching
their app with Material Design
increased user
engagement by 100%.
They also share how WeVideo
improved monetization
and installs using ratings
and reviews, store listing
experiments, and other
features on Google Play.
Click the link for
the full video.
Quickly understand your cloud
application's top or new errors
with Stackdriver
Error Reporting now
available in beta
for everyone to try.
Zero set-up is needed for
App Engine applications,
and it requires just a
few configuration steps
on other platforms.
Stackdriver Error
Reporting counts, analyzes,
and aggregates in real time the
crashes in your running cloud
services and notifies you
when there's something new.
More details and screenshots
are in the linked post.
We recently launched the Google
Maps SDK for iOS version 1.13.
This release
includes the ability
to create advanced marker
animations, the ability
to set the frame
rate up to 60 frames
per second, further
custom styling
for the place auto
autocomplete widget, and more.
Details and a link to
the SDK are on the post.
OK, that was a super short
set of updates this week.
So here's one more
thing just for fun.
This is a post on the Google
Research blog from the Broad
Institute of MIT and
Harvard about how
their researchers and
software engineers
are collaborating closely
with the Google genomics
team on large-scale
genomic data analysis.
They've already significantly
reduced the time and cost
for whole genome
processing and are helping
researchers think even bigger.
Check it out.
And that's it.
With the time we
saved today, why
don't you share this video with
your friends and colleagues.
Go on.
They'll thank you for it.
And don't forget to click all
the links in the description
below.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next time.